bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue dans ce sens public 90 minutes
de débats et d analyse pour vous donner
des clés de compréhension de l'actualité
et des mutations de la société française
avec au sommaire de ce 9 décembre la
conférence de presse des manuels macro
évidemment pour lancer les priorités de
la présidence tournante de l'union
européenne pour la première fois depuis
13 ans c'est au tour de la france à
partir du 1er janvier immigration
défense nouveau modèle de croissance que
faut-il en attente de cette présidence
est ce aussi une chance pour un
président de plus en plus candidat ce
sera notre débats d'actu pour notre
reportage au coeur des territoires les
électeurs ont la parole une polémique
qui prend de l'ampleur identité
gastronomiques ou bien être animal vous
entendrez ce soir un chef lyonnais face
à la décision de son maire et de
plusieurs élus écologistes et
socialistes de bannir le foie gras des
événements de leur ville et puis dans
cette émission passe régulièrement au
crible les propositions des candidats
dans cette campagne présidentielle des
candidats et des candidates ce soir les
quotas d'immigration voté chaque année
par le parlement idée neuve où il
écourte c'est une promesse de valérie
pécresse
mais d'abord donc les priorités de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne détaillé par jonathan du prix
m
emmanuel macron était sur son terrain de
prédilection l'europe devant un parterre
de journalistes le chef de l'état a
présenté sa feuille de route pour la
présidence française de l'ue eux
emmanuel macron prendra les rênes de
l'union pour six mois dès le 1er janvier
nous devons passer d'une europe de
coopération à l'intérieur de nos
frontières à une europe puissante dans
le monde pleinement souveraine libre de
ses choix et maître de son destin et
c'est ça l'objectif autour d'un
triptyque relance puissance appartenance
emmanuel macron a détaillé ses dossiers
prioritaires
renforcer la maîtrise des flux
migratoires aux frontières de l'europe
repenser le cadre budgétaire européen ou
encore avancé sur la politique de
défense communautaire
cette présidence sera à cet égard à un
moment de définition de ce que nous
avons appelé la boussole stratégiques
c'est-à-dire un livre blanc européen de
défense et de sécurité
qui à la fois présentera l'état des
menaces et fixera nos choix collectifs
nos orientations nos ambitions en
européen convaincu emmanuel macron s'est
aussi projeté dans le futur appelant à
définir ce qu'ils appellent l'europe de
2030 il nous faut définir ensemble ce
que sera l'europe de 2030 notre europe
doit être une europe où on puisse
produire créer de la richesse de la
richesse est à la pointe de l'innovation
une europe aussi qui doit défendre son
modèle social parce que nous n'avons pas
les mêmes choix collectifs que l'asie ou
les états unis d'amérique et une europe
qui doit être au coeur de l'agenda
climatique qui est aussi qui correspond
à nos valeurs
si emmanuel macron entend montrer son
rôle moteur lors de cette présidence
tournante ses marges de manoeuvre risque
d'être limitée des désaccords sont
possibles avec les 26 autres états
membres et son agenda européen risque de
se télescoper avec la campagne
présidentielle
emmanuel macron face à la presse on va
débattre de la forme mais aussi et
surtout du fond avec mes invités gérard
longuet bonsoir
de la meuse xavier iacovelli bonsoir cm2
des hauts-de-seine catherine tricot
directrice de la revue regards avec nous
en duplex sylvie matelly qui est
économiste directrice adjoint de l'iris
bonsoir à vous aussi laetitia crêpa
éditorialiste politique vous étiez à
l'elysée cet après midi voilà il a fallu
revenir vite
les priorités européennes d'emmanuel
macron c'est ce qui est est au menu au
programme avec un emblème pour la
présidence française de l'union
européenne avec des mots clés qui ont
été détaillées par le secrétaire d'état
clément bonne pour pour démarrer la
relance la puissance
l'appartenance
bref gérard longuet quel regard vous
portez sur cette opportunité pour la
française que vous le vivez comme ça
tient c'est assurément une opportunité
pour des raison d'accidents politique ça
tombe pas vraiment au bon moment pendant
la république a un mandat très amputés
et il est en campagne ce qui ne favorise
pas son autorité au sein de l'union
européenne sur l'ordre du jour retenu
par emmanuel macron n'y a rien à dire ce
sont les vrais sujets sur les raisons de
penser qu'il va pouvoir remporter une
décision marquante dans des domaines
comme l'immigration comme la défense ou
comme la nouvelle croissance je n'en
vois absolument aucun prémices en tous
les cas il ne les a pas livré si ce
n'est la confiance en lui même je quitte
une vertu mais c'est pas une vertu
suffisante vous avez effectivement il ya
il ya un petit côté incantatoire dans
une conférence de presse comme celle là
même si nous donne un calendrier des
événements des réunions des sommets
thématique il ya quand même ça ça dépend
de deux choses 1 sont son destin
politique personnelle et puis deux la
volonté des partenaires enfin les
partenaires
il ne fait pas une conférence de presse
et on ne commence pas en fait une
présidence de l'union européenne sans
avoir déjà travaillé et nos diplomates
travaillent depuis plusieurs semaines et
plusieurs mois à la préparation de cette
présidence de l'union européenne et donc
effectivement il ya des grandes
priorités des grandes priorités qui sont
aussi propres à la france et qui est que
la france veut impulser dans cette
présidence de l'union européenne je
pense au pacte vert je pense aux
directives relatives au salaire minimum
et ça c'est déjà il ya déjà un préaccord
on va dire des pays européens sur sur
cette question ait donc je pense que
c'est important qu'on puisse
accentué effectivement l'ordre de 7
cette présidence et puis il ya aussi
tous et que cette coopération retrouver
avec avec l'afrique avec les balkans
occidentaux ça c'est aussi des éléments
importants que le président de mettre en
avant dans cette résidence catherine
tricot le premier tel qu'il le prenne la
république
revenu c'est l'immigration absolument
n'y a rien de très original moi j'ai
trouvé dans les trois thèmes qu'il a mis
en avant immigration défense nouveau
modèle de croissance qui ressemble
diablement à celui qu'il propose pour la
france le copier coller entre l'europe
2030 et la france 2030 donc tout est
assez classique alors on vous parlait de
choses qui sont bien intéressante
l'écologie les salaires les inégalités
la relation avec l'afrique mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas très
présent dans la conférence de presse en
tout cas ça ne ressort pas comme étant
les grands axes qui s'était quand même
très présent dans la conférence de
presse notamment la conférence annonce a
évoqué comment sur le thème de
l'immigration
parce que c'est un sujet important aux
personnes qui ont leur nom mais quel que
soit les on voit d'ailleurs les
problèmes avec laurent odile se
positionne sur du régalien très
fortement et sur des thèmes qui sont pas
très novateur on veut dire qu'il hante
l'europe et il ne propose pas un nouveau
projet pour l'europe qui le ferait et
devrait sortir un peu la tête de l'eau
et lui donnerait une grande perspective
c'est quand même pas les sujets sur
lequel il ainsi ce sont des sujets un
peu rebattu certes c'est pas parce
qu'ils sont rebattues qui sont pas ceux
nécessaires dans jusque les essaims mais
par contre d'écologie quand même très
peu présents qui propose de mobiliser la
finance pour le pacte vert bon c'est pas
non plus
d'une ambition de dengue à dire sylvie
matelly 7,7 présidence tournante est ce
que moi la vraie question me pose c'est
est-ce que c'est un vrai levier d'action
et si on regarde un peu dans le
rétroviseur de ce qui s'est passé avec
d'autres présidence tournante au voyez
ce que je veux dire oui alors salle et
moi aujourd'hui que ça n'aidait par le
passé parce qu'on a renforcé sa tout les
pouvoirs de la commission voire voir
avoir dû des autres institutions de
l'union européenne donc pour le coup on
est quand même sur quelque chose qui est
beaucoup plus collectif et où le rôle du
du conseil et des états et de l'état qui
préside durant cette présidence
tournante est moindre que par le passé
somme toute ce qu'on peut constater
c'est que mêmes belle macro et quand
même depuis cinq ans le président le qui
depuis qu'il ya eu une véritable
politique européenne avec une une
ambition ou blaine extrêmement forte ça
n'était pas arrivé moi je serais tenté
de dire depuis le premier mandat de
jacques chirac qui à la fin des années
90 avait lancé un simple manque
d'initiative avec le président avec le
premier ministre britannique tony blair
donc on est quand même dans une dans un
contexte où ce président français est
attendu sur ces questions européennes et
puis c'est vrai que tous les sujets
qu'il a abordés sont aujourd'hui des
sujets des dossiers qui sont largement
déjà entamé bien ouverts dans les
discussions européennes
il sait pas et c'est pas spécifiquement
mouiller la question de la souveraineté
c'est une question qui apparaît même
dans des textes et des déclarations des
polonais sur ce sur ce sujet ce qui
n'était pas le cas il ya 4 5 ans donc on
voit que sur tous ces sujets en avance
la question de l'immigration c'est une
préoccupation qui est partagé par tous
les européens sur la question de la
croissance c'était peut-être assez
original que de l'appréhender comme ça
malgré tout on voit qu'il a quand même
donné des gages sur le pacte de
stabilité il recourt au pacte de
stabilité donc on s'aperçoit pas même
qu'il marche sur des oeufs lait qu'ils
avaient bien préparé comme ça a été dit
en amont c'est ces dossiers nul doute
qu'il a également consulté étudier le
trait et consulter directement l'équipe
qui rendent qui arrivent au pouvoir
en allemagne pour s'assurer d'un certain
nombre de choses et dans les mots qu'il
a employés ont recours un certain nombre
de mots qui sont communs avec le
programme qui a été présentée par par la
coalition qui prend le pouvoir en
allemagne ces jours ci il en discutera
demain à l'occasion de la venue du
nouveau chancelier allemand donc oui
l'ambition est énorme surtout quand la
plante bien que cette présidence de va
pouvoir durer en réalité que deux mois
et demi puisque les élections françaises
vont empêcher que ça se poursuivra après
le 3 mars
vous demander de ne pas faire des
réponses trop longue histoire que la
parole puisse savoir l'identité et que
ce moment de mes yeux je reviendrai vers
vous sans faute sylvie matelly j'ai
plein de questions et je suis sûr vous
faites des grands signer je vous redonne
la parole ça sans problème à un mot
peut-être de contexte laetitia c'est que
cette conférence bon il y avait vraiment
cette volonté macron alors il continue
et on diffusera évidemment des extraits
au fur et à mesure de rester sur le sur
l'europe et sur la présidence tournante
bah oui l'a dit de façon très claire à
la fin de son préambule qui a duré plus
d'une heure c'est très long avec
emmanuel macron donc c'est vrai que
quand arrive le moment des questions
avec les journalistes on peut avoir
peut-être un peu perdu le fil même si
c'est toujours des plans entre en partie
parce que vous en avez oublié une
catherine c'est quand même l'europe
humanisme est là avec notamment revoir
justement éviter de réviser l'histoire
il a envoyé un pic pic on sait très bien
à ceux qui sont tentés de réviser
l'histoire européenne donc il veut
convoquer les historiens pour écrire
l'histoire de l'europe il ya aussi une
législation européenne contre les
violences faites aux femmes donc il ya
quand même comme ça aux journalistes
dans le soutien au journalisme
d'investigation d'investigation a
effectivement donc il ya quand même un
troisième pilier mais c'est vrai que
tout de suite après il nous a dit bon
voilà maintenant place aux questions je
suis ravi de répondre à nos questions
mais d'abord ce seront des questions sur
l'europe ensuite ce seront des questions
sur l'international et peut-être s'il y
en a même si ce n'est pas le lieu le
moment c'est toujours cadré il faudrait
oui mais est-ce qu'on est obligé de
suivre le cadre enfin je sais pas je
pose la question est ce qu'on est obligé
quand le président nous dit écoutez moi
je suis là je vous ai convoqués pour ces
thèmes là est ce qu'on est obligé d'y
rester vraisemblablement en tout cas les
journalistes ils sont restés puisque
quand je suis parti on est encore en
train de parler de l'europe c'est
intéressant c'est pas la question c'est
juste que est-ce qu'il va y avoir ou non
à 19h30 une question sur sur la france
et oui déjà eu quelques questions en
lien avec la avec la politique
intérieure la campagne et après c'est au
président de décider d'y répondre
longuement ou pas ils avaient plutôt
tendance à répondre longuement
évidemment sur la présidence française
de l'union est très rapidement sur sur
leur est si on reste là on reviendra au
fond 1 mais si on reste sur cette forme
peut-être gérard longuet est ce que pour
vous c'est un exercice démocratique
important on va voir pendant que vous
nous répondez le nombre de conférences
de presse présidentiel qui ont été
faites par les prédécesseurs les deux
derniers prédécesseurs des mamelles
macro nicolas sarkozy c'était 4 françois
hollande c'était 6 est ce que ça vous
semble important ce type de rendez vous
oui tout à fait mais c'est pas un
exercice que emmanuel macron affectionne
manifestement il est plutôt avare d'une
certaine façon pourquoi pas non moi ce
que je regrette dans son approche il ya
quand même de grands pays en europe
l'allemagne d'abord et la france ensuite
nous avons une nouvelle équipe en
allemagne qui est très différente et je
crois que cela méritait peut-être soit
de reporter la conférence après la
rencontre avec le chancelier allemand
qui vient à paris soit 2 d'avoir des
contacts plus clair pour savoir si un
certain nombre d'options par exemple la
nouvelle croissance par exemple
l'énergie je suis assez branché sur ces
questions d'énergie il nous sommes en
désaccord total avec nous et nos voisins
allemands
finances on commet finances soit le
nucléaire
aussi c'est à dire avec les allemands on
est d'accord sur tout sauf sur
l'essentiel bien c'est un petit peu
l'impression plan n'a aujourd'hui et
j'aurais aimé que le le délai très court
la présidence ça va être trois mois
effectifs mais trois mois effective
d'entente avec une nouvelle majorité
allemandes on pouvait peut-être apporter
quelque chose là on est sur notre faim
et on ne sait pas avec qui et vers quoi
quand on prend on parle d'indépendance
stratégique c'est formidable il faut
quand même se souvenir que les allemands
ont une balance commerciale excédentaire
avec la chine et qui n'ont donc pas du
tout la même conception que nous avons
de nos relations commerciales avec ce
grand des lycées mais vous avez raison
j'ai eu l'impression qu'à chaque fois
qu'il a répondu sur ces questions là il
y avait des questions très précises su
par exemple pourquoi on continue
d'importer des masques de chine c'est
très précis ça nous concerne tous ça
concerne les français emmanuel macron et
répond avec des concepts c'est à dire
qu'il a et 6 me la ccir et là pendant la
conférence de presse de parler de
l'europe mais de façon très théorique
alors que vous avez raison monsieur
longuet pour mr question c'est ça ne
fonctionne pas c'est pragmatique à 27
c'est compliqué on n'y arrive pas et
comment faire est-ce qu'on change de
modèle est ce qu ont continué et s'est
un peu non on va continuer comme cela
parce que c'est bon c'est tout à l'heure
aux cibles non c'est pas possible xavier
quand il perd une double double réponse
à gérard longuet finalement est ce que
dit laeticia peut-être d'abord sur la
date est là et la prééminence de du duo
franco-allemand j'imagine qu'il ya eu
quelques contacts avec olaf scholz de
positionnement quelques semaines donc
peut-être que effectivement les propos
du président lors de cette conférence
tiennent compte de la feuille de route
qui a été validée par la coalition
allemand et puis ensuite sur le côté un
peu trop peut-être conceptuelle des
réponses du président oui répond déjà la
première intervention celle où parler
que d'europe et est pas de la france
mais en même temps c'était une
conférence de presse sur la présidence
française de l'union européenne donc je
sais qu'en france on n'est pas forcément
toujours très intéressés par la question
européenne mais ça conditionne aussi
beaucoup notre quotidien notre quotidien
et donc je pense que c'est important que
le président de la république puisse
mettre m 7 cette question en avant et
qui répondent sur les questions
européennes et internationales et d'une
façon peut-être trop conceptuel disentis
accrue
passé c'est votre conception en tout cas
de ce qu'il a pu dire je pense il est il
allé sur l'essentiel sur les grands
grands thèmes c'est une conférence de
presse sur l'apple annoncé la présidence
de nom de l'union européenne donc si
vous voulez on n'est pas encore dans le
concret là il annoncé l'agenda il
annonçait les conférences il annoncé les
objectifs et les ambitions se pressent
pour ça très honnêtement mais personne
une fois les journalistes après la crise
des filets jaunes c'était un moment
critique a crucial dans son quinquennat
et là on se dit pourquoi maintenant en
fait si c'est uniquement pour
développer à megan qui l'avait pourquoi
au lieu alors qu'il nous parle même pas
de sarkozy dit qu'il n'a pas non mais
non mais vous êtes qu il est 3eme tels
que son intervention
tout et son contraire on ne peut pas
dire que le président la république ne
couvre que jamais la presse pour des
conférences de presse et que là le jour
où il convoque la presse sur un sujet
important
j'invite oui la vie par d'un pardonnez
moi monsieur longuet ne pas utiliser le
bon mot donc il invite la presse lors
d'une conférence de presse à l'elysée
sur la question européenne et la
présidence française je ne vois pas en
quoi il ya un problème de
parler de l'union européenne et le
parler de cette présidence y a un agenda
qui a été portée il ya des valeurs qui
ont été réaffirmés d'une ambition
française pour réaffirmer ses valeurs à
l'échelle européenne
une ambition aussi de souveraineté de
pacte écologique de 2 kg pour la
question de la de l'entente avec le
nouveau pouvoir france 2 fait son fiancé
fait confiance au gouvernement et
notamment à jean yves le drian et à
clément bonne pour avoir pris des en
amont les contacts avec le nouveau
chancelier son équipe avant même qu'il
soit d'ailleurs installé définitivement
pour justement calais un certain nombre
d'éléments de langage et de préparation
de cette présidence française enfin
parler en mois mais ce sont ses seuls ce
ne sont pas des amateurs quand on y
reviendra notamment sur la question de
l'orthodoxie budget
certains estiment en partant je dis on
juge l'arbre à ses fruits ce ne sont pas
des amateurs dont l'agenda est correct
il est complet il est assez exhaustif il
est exhaustif mais on ne voit en rien
par quelles modalités on parviendra en
trois mois à ce que l'on a alors pu
faire depuis dix je vais donner la
parole lisa ou président l'accasion si
vous voulez j'ai un premier extrait qui
conserve ce qui concerne pardon le fait
justement d'être présent république
peut-être bientôt candidat et d'avoir
cette casquette de président tournant de
l'union européenne en écoute la réponse
du président français il nous faut tenir
notre rang notre rôle avec l'esprit de
responsabilité en considérant que c'est
la france qui est aussi une continuité
que les sujets dont on parle sont ceux
qui sont poussés depuis plusieurs années
qu'ils sont intérêts de la france et de
l'europe et donc je veillerai à faire
cela au demeurant j'essaie de le faire
depuis quatre ans alors est ce que
toutes les sensibilités politiques
qui dans le les discussions
démocratiques qui s'organisera en france
dans les prochains mois ont la même
perception de cet agenda à coup sûr non
et donc
ça ce sera le je dirais la vie
démocratique de notre nation qui à
partir de la fin du mois d'avril dira
sur ces sujets les positions que tiendra
la france peut-être que la politique de
la france changera à coup sûr la france
restera la france
sylvie matelly commencé perçu justement
ce cette double casquette par par nos
partenaires européens
commençaient perçu cette double
casquette je ne suis pas certain qu'il
n'y ait une réelle conscience de cela au
niveau européen je suis pas certaine que
ce soit des questions que se posent les
européens simplement ce qui est ce qui
est certain c'est que effectivement le
président va très certainement vouloir
accélérer la cadence pour faire passer
d'initiatives que possible sur un
programme ça a été soulignée qui est
extrêmement dense extrêmement complet et
nos partenaires européens où
généralement besoin d'un petit peu plus
de temps donc il risque d'y avoir des
frustrations côté français au départ
parce que ça n'avance pas assez vite et
côté de mon partenaire au départ aussi
parce qu'on essaye de les faire aller
plus vite que la musique alors après je
note qu' un certain nombre de dossiers
qui sont de fait déjà à l'agenda qui
sont déjà dans les programmes
d'aidé discussions européennes et qui ne
ce qui seront portés par la france avec
toute la volonté nécessaire pour que ça
avance et que ça aboutit je pense par
exemple à la boussole stratégie compte
il est prévu depuis la présidence
allemande qu'elle sera finalisée cette
douceur stratégique ce document
stratégique de défense qu'elle sera
finalisée au premier semestre
2022 donc lors de la présidence
française donc ça c'est quelque chose
qui est déjà dans les têtes et à adapter
par tarak autres et tout le monde mais
je reviens sur par exemple cette
conférence qui est prévue au mois de
mars début mars avec les chaînes sur un
27 ans on est bien d'accord sur le
nouveau modèle européen de croissance
ciblée matelly on sera un mois tout
juste du premier tour de la
présidentielle je ne peux pas croire que
certains des partenaires européens de la
france ne tique pas un petit peu quand
même
la france aura la présidence tournante
de l'ue eux et sera dans son rôle que le
coin des initiatives à ce niveau là donc
je ne suis pas certaine que
liebig et un problème par rapport à ça
la question qui se posera au moment de
cette conférence c'est est-ce que
emmanuel macron est en position de
favori et valence remporté cette
élection est donc va pouvoir poursuivre
les initiatives qu'il a lancés ou pas et
c'est à ce moment là en fait que ça va
véritablement s'exprimer parce que si
vous êtes face à un président candidat
qui n'est pas favori ou dont on pense
qu'il ne sera pas élu bien évidemment la
conférence peut faire refaire
[Musique]
du tout à la fin parce qu'il n'a aucune
crédibilité
laëtitia vont intervenir oui justement
consorts à la presse qui a pris la
parole tout de suite deuxième question
il me semble et qui a demandé oui au
président parce que elle avait des échos
de justement de ses confrères européens
et de et des chefs d'état européens qui
justement 10ème mais comment ça va être
possible de pouvoir avoir un cap et puis
une gouvernance correct alors qu' il y à
ces sessions française donc bien sûr que
ça pose un problème évidemment c'est au
coeur de la problématique d'autant que
la france pouvait échanger plus son tour
alors on pouvait changer et maquereau a
expliqué que c'était je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez xavier la comédie mais
que c'était compliqué d'échangés parce
que d'autres pays qui était avant ou
après nous avait aussi des aussi des
échéances électorales on aurait pu
décaler la date de la présidence france
chargé avec de l'union pour nous que ça
ne vois là ne
ne viennent pas en pleine campagne
priori franchement moi je pense que
encore une fois la france incarne
quelque chose un terrain des valeurs nez
hormis un séisme au mois d'avril on
restera sur ce socle de valeurs et sur
globalement un pays qui est pro européen
et qui défend un certain nombre de
sujets enfin il ya quand même une
manière d'être de ne pas afin d'être pro
européen et c'est qu'en fait ça fait
l'objet d'un débat politique
emmanuel macron fait une proposition et
puis il ya d'autres manières de le voir
et c'est assez étrange oui d'ailleurs un
enjeu dans ce cas vous avez vous avez
raison de le soulever parce
qu'effectivement les élèves défendre des
chaudes pour l'europe au niveau de la
france c'est défendre l' inverse quand
ils sont au parlement européen vous avez
complètement raison de le soulever mais
moi je pense encore une fois qu'on a
aujourd'hui on a un socle de valeurs
communes on est on a un président de la
république qui a porté pendant son
mandat de président français un certain
nombre de sujets à l'échelle européenne
je pense notamment à la taxation des
gaffes à sévère c'est une initiative
française qui est maintenant repris dans
cette présidence française de l'union
européenne et qui a maintenant aussi à
l'échelon européen et que tous les pays
ont validé ces 2 15% de de taxation pour
les gaffes a même adressé c'est vous
pouvez vous pouvez estimer que ce n'est
pas assez enfin juste c'est la première
fois qu'on met ça en place et c'est à
l'initiative du président de la
république donc il ya un certain nombre
de sujets si vous voulez moi je pense
qu'on a la chance d'avoir un président
entier pro européens qui souhaitent plus
d'europe et non pas moins d'europe à de
repli sur soi mais cette façon'
déclinistes face aux défaitistes on est
on a un président qui est progressiste
et qui veut vraiment aller sur wii
une europe une europe aussi de l'emploi
tout ça ce sont des projets que que
emmanuel macron portes aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron soit européen c'est
certain c'est d'ailleurs un aspect
plutôt sympathique de sa personnalité et
simplement le calendrier le confronte à
deux risques soit de vouloir aboutir à
tout prix et je pense en particulier à
la taxonomie sur l'énergie c'est à dire
faire des concessions pour pouvoir dire
j'ai obtenu un accord ou au contraire se
lancer sur un projet plus ambitieux et
avoir des partenaires qui connaissant sa
fragilité politique joue la montre et se
disent il va être obligé de calais et
d'accepter quelque chose et je pense
profondément que ne pas avoir interverti
affaibli la france alors c'est un jeu
personnel il ya le droit de jouer mais
c'est les intérêts de l'europe et
d'intérêts de la france qui étendait qui
prend un risque d'une sauvagerie ce côté
personnel lui est-ce-qu'il lourd louise
et pour la france après ou et le prend
pour la france 2 fait parce qu'il est le
président de la république française
ici nous avons un mauvais accord pour
tenir dans le calendrier nous le
paierons longtemps quatrième je pense en
particulier c'est ce qu'a fait lionel
jospin en 2000 à barcelone l'accord sur
l'énergie était absurde on l'accepté
enfin le gouvernement de cohabitation
l'a acceptée parce qu'il fallait un
succès à la veille des élections de 2002
on le paye encore aujourd'hui un peu
comme les accords de dublin peut-être
quatre entre les grands sujets sur
lequel il a mis sur la table et ce qu'il
n'a pas mis sur la table mérités de
quand même avoir le temps de la concorde
l'arrêt maturité de la maturité or là on
va devoir aller à marche forcée ce qui
fait que probablement ces grands sujets
qui sont sur la table depuis dix ans
peut-être resteront t-il encore un petit
peu plus parce que je ne vois pas
comment deux trois mois sauf il va
aboutir probablement à ce qui est déjà
quasiment mur
essayez de ça on voit les value
effectivement restent les premiers faire
il va pas pouvoir faire grand chose on
jouera à la fin d'un précédent projet
europe 2030 comment voulez-vous quand
d'autres deux mois et demi parce que
c'est le 20 mars à qu'il est tenu à la
réserve donc ça fait deux mois et demi
mais on ne demande ni réglera pas en fin
d'année parce qu'ils sont bien ces 24 25
mars posselt les noter
à partir du 20 mars alors on va prendre
on va prendre le temps d'un petit coup
d'oeil dans le rétroviseur avec
alexandre alexandre poussin bono nous
rejoindre pouvoir se comment ça s'était
passé la dernière fois que la france ait
pris la présidence tournante de l'union
européenne 2008 nicolas sarkozy que
peut-on retenir alors il ya un parallèle
historique très intéressant à faire
thomas puisque dans cette conférence de
presse emmanuel macron a déclaré que
l'union européenne ne devait pas
boycotter diplomatiquement les jeux
olympiques d'hiver à pékin qui vont se
dérouler durant l'hiver 2022 ans
contrairement à la position américaine
qui est pour et bien un boycott
diplomatique à cause des problèmes de
respect des droits de l'homme en chine
et en 2008 au moment où nicolas sarkozy
prend la présidence tournante de l'union
européenne eh bien il a la même position
qu emmanuel macron il refuse un boycott
diplomatique des jeux olympiques d'été
2008 à pékin et bien quand il se
présente devant le parlement européen au
début de sa présidence ils étaient
interpellés de manière très vigoureuse
par l'eurodéputé daniel cohn bendit sur
ce sujet souvenez vous vous allez manger
avec des baguettes avec le président de
chine pour ouvrir les soldes olympique
bon appétit moi je penserai à tous les
prisonniers qui croupissent dans
l'épisode prisons chinoises comment dire
à la chine aidez nous à faire la paix
dans le monde assurer la stabilité dans
le monde et en même temps boycotter la
chine au moment d'un événement est
essentiel pour 1 milliard 300 millions
d'habitants
voilà donc l'histoire se répète de ce
point de vue en tout cas en 2008 nicolas
sarkozy il a commencé très fort sa
présidence française de l'union
européenne puisque en août 2008 éclate
la guerre en géorgie une guerre pour
l'indépendance des deux républiques
séparatistes à des province d'ossétie du
sud et d'abkhazie soutenu par l'armée
russe et à ce moment là nicolas sarkozy
au monde lyon il va à moscou pour
essayer de calmer un peu le président
russe dimitri medvedev et puis il va
également à tbilissi en géorgie et il
réussit à arracher un cessez le feu
grâce à un travail de médiation écouter
j'appelle chacun
où qu'il se trouve
à respecter la lettre et l'esprit
pour que les déplacés et les réfugiés
puissent retrouver leur maison
pour que les morts inutiles ça cesse
pour qu'il y ait moins de souffrance et
pour que dans le calme la communauté
internationale puisse apporter des
réponses à l'aspiration à la stabilité à
la sécurité et à la paix alors il ya eu
une crise de grande ampleur que nicolas
sarkozy a dû gérer en tant que président
du conseil européen c'est la crise
financière de 2008 la crise des
subprimes ce qui vient des états unis et
qui fait tombé comme un château de
cartes toute l'économie européenne alors
nicolas sarkozy essaye de mobiliser la
solidarité entre les états membres
européens et quand il vient devant le
parlement européen il prend même des
accents un peu lyrique un peu
révolutionnaire face au monde de la
finance écoutez
europe doit porter l'idée d'une
refondation du capitalisme mondial
ce qui s'est passé c'est la trahison des
valeurs du capitalisme
ce n'est pas la remise en cause de
l'économie de marché
alors au final on peut pas dire que le
capitalisme mondial a été refondée mais
en tout cas cette présidence française
de l'union européenne a donné une
dimension internationale au mandat
nicolas sarkozy merci beaucoup merci
alexandre c'est intéressant parce qu'on
voit bien quelle opportunité
d'action et de communication vont se
présenter pour emmanuel macron et on
comprend aussi pourquoi
continuer à vous voulez vous que je sois
mail ici un second tour un peu de malice
un déplacement dossier d'un semestre
aurait permis un nouveau président de
présenter les intérêts de la france et
de l'europe avec toute leur autorité
l'expérience acquise au cours du premier
mandat encore fallait-il que ce candidat
soit certain d'avoir un deuxième mandat
où donc est ce l'expression d'un doute
sur son deuxième mandat je passais mâcon
12 500 mans je pense que la question du
juge des mandats n'est pas forcément
dans l'esprit aujourd'hui de la décision
de française de prendre la présidence ou
pas les y avait un agenda la présidence
française bombay effectivement au 1er
janvier 2022 ça n'a pas été remis en
cause et pardonnez moi mais jusqu'à
preuve du contraire rien ne laisse à
penser qu'il n'y aurait pas de deuxième
mandat et je trouve que je vois
divertissement un deuxième mandat mais
lui donne le 100e lors de votre
certitude votre certitude sur la
fragilité du président de la république
laisse à penser que peut-être vous avez
eu un peu trop d'ambition pour la
candidate que vous défendrez alors ce
qui est étrange quand on écoute ses
archives c'est qu'on écoute nicolas
sarkozy quand même avec un peu de
souffle moi ce que j'ai trouvé tout à
l'heure lorsque les
gens sont bien mais le discours de
nicolas sarkozy c'est nous allons
refonder le capitalisme etc enfin bon
rhume et le filet c'est bien le 10 mais
ce qu'il en était advenu on ne juge pas
la crise mais lui pour l'instant autant
tout cas si on ne part pas avec une
ambition on est sûr qu on n'arrivera à
rien de sûr on ne peut pas dire que le
discours d' emmanuel macron cet
après-midi était pétri d'une ambition de
refondations d'une europe écologique
social qui allait apporter les nouvelles
machines dans la victoire les trois mois
dont ils disposent donc oui mais ils
n'avaient mais il n'a même pas énoncer
cela il a remis des dossiers classique
et régalien et il n'a pas énoncés un
discours qui pourrait faire battre le
coeur des français des européens silva
avec ça je suis pas certaine que sa
présidence restera inoubliable on a
quand même été humilié par les états
unis dans la sphère australienne et par
l'angleterre d'ailleurs on lorsqu'il
parle de la boussole stratégique on
aurait aimé qu'il nous dise quelque
chose sur l'europe qui prend sa liberté
vis-à-vis d'un systéme atlantique trop
autoritaire et trop marginalisant comme
des enfants mineurs assister les pays
européens et l'eau commence mais il
revient des hommes il le dit un petit
peu c'est moi c'est l'oseille la famille
que j'ai trouvé vraiment un peu un
nouvel j'allais dire c'est quand il
parle de l'alliance entre l'europe et
l'afrique on voit qu emmanuel macron
essaie de construire je dirais un impact
euro afrique qui peut jouer face aux
déplacements du monde du côté du
pacifique avec les états unis d'une part
et la chine d'autre part c'est à dire
que l'europe ne se suffira pas elle a
besoin de se conforter avec l'afrique et
ça je trouve qu'il ya une idée il est un
peu nos angoisses et moi j'ai trouvé
tout sens mais bien sûr il ne parle de
la russie ah oui je le regrette mais
c'est peut-être là où le four joint à la
forme et c'est peut être pour cette
raison qu'il n'aurait pas dû choisir les
la conférence de presse parce que vous
avez raison son discours n'avait pas le
souffle nécessaire pour emmener les
futurs électeurs les futures européen
convaincu enfin le peuple d'europe le
peuple de france parce que on est à
l'elysée devant effectivement sans
journalistes et que le cadre à la forme
n'est pas cohérente avec ce type de
discours ou peut-être aurait paru un peu
décalé en tout cas ça n'a pas eu lieu
donc peut-être qu'effectivement un
déplacement avec un pupitre une prise de
parole a été plus judicieuse plutôt que
de donner un petit peu comme ça à la
presse l'impression de la recevoir une
seconde fois alors que c'était
finalement pas capital
sylvie matelly une question sur sur ce
set en jeu du nouveau modèle européen de
de croissance effectivement emmanuel
macron a évoqué la question de
l'orthodoxie budgétaire de la sortie de
la règle des 3% des déficits là aussi
est ce que c'est compatible avec ce que
les allemands ce que le nouveau pouvoir
allemand a annoncé c'est à dire un
retour à l'orthodoxie dès 2023
alors je pense que ce qu'on voit et ça
ça va je ne vais pas je vais pas
répondre directement à votre question
mais mais ça il répond malgré tout et ça
réagit à ce qui a été dit précédemment
en fait ce qu'on a vu dans ce discours
d' emmanuel macron c'est qu'il n'a pas
cherché uniquement à séduire de
potentiels électeurs et des français il
a aussi essayé de rassurer de convaincre
les européens les pays européens parce
que finalement dans le temps qui lui est
imparti il a besoin du soutien des
européens et en europe pour moi ce qui
m'a surprise ces dernières années c'est
qu'on cite très très très souvent le
discours de la sorbonne c'est à dire le
premier discours de politique européenne
prononcé par emmanuel macron au début de
son mandat c'est quelque chose qui a
énormément marqué les européens est
pourquoi parce qu'il est perçu comme le
porteur de la construction européenne le
dirigeant européen qui est probablement
le plus convaincu de l'intérêt de
l'europe et qui est dans une logique de
reconstruction et de restauration en
fait de cette grande idée européenne on
est d'accord on n'est pas d'accord mais
il ya cette idée là et donc je pense que
j'ai entendue dans toute la prudence qui
l'a exprimé en mai l'impasse sur
certains dossiers c'était cette volonté
de rassurer de la même manière il l'a
fait avec le pacte de stabilité pour les
allemands parce qu'il a bien noté 7 cet
élément dans le programme de cette
nouvelle coalition mais il n'est pas
allé beaucoup plus loin parce que bas
dans la vraie vie que l'on fait et là je
suis bien incapable de répondre à votre
question parce que pour l'instant nous
n'avons pas encore de programme
défini le programme de delà de sa
prochaine présidence de sa de sa
campagne en fait son programme sont
quand même dans le cas de l'élection
présidentielle et on a assez peu de
visibilité sur ce qu'il va annoncer et
qui plus est là être en place gênées aux
entournures parce que une austérité qui
nous conduiraient par exemple les nôtres
déficits et rembourser une partie de nos
têtes dc dc
quelques quelques mois voire quelques
années ça paraît quand même très très
difficile à porter dans le cas d'une
élection présidentielle effectivement et
puis c'est pas très cohérent avec
l'ambition qui a été affiché sur les
nouvelles filières en matière de pêche
des espaces d'hydrogène etc etc
j'aimerais qu'on entende un autre
extrait de la conférence de presse de
d'emmanuel macron il est questionné sur
la candidature d'eric zemmour et y
répond avec les valeurs écoute emmanuel
macron notre pays est
un vieux pays fait de valeurs de culture
de combat
et qu'il s'est à chaque fois grandi
d'avoir su regarder cette défaite mais
d'avoir su consolider ses valeurs
et aimer la france et respecter les
français
c'est au fond avoir une certaine idée de
la grandeur de la france
c'est respecter la dignité
de chaque française de chaque français
parce que c'est ce faisant respecter la
dignité de notre nation j'ai pas
d'autres commentaires à faire
est-ce que c'est l'image de l'europe qui
est finalement que portait et puis les
des valeurs de l'europe c'est ça ce que
je veux dire que porte emmanuel macron
peut-être c'est ça la vraie raison de
cette conférence de presse qui lui
permet à la fois d'annoncer son
programme pour les mois à venir pour les
trois ou six mois à venir mais aussi de
répondre à la droite à l'extrême droite
sur le débat identité là qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette idée xavier qu il y
avait c'était 1 2 en 1 d'une certaine
façon oui c'était peut-être peut-être un
deux en un mais la france a toujours par
ses valeurs a toujours infuser aussi
dans les valeurs européennes et qui a
toujours impulsé cette cette ambition
européenne et ses valeurs européennes
humaniste cela même s'il n'est pas
officiellement en campagne c'est lui
permet de se démarquer sur ce qu est un
thème majeur de la campagne qu'on lui
pose une question sur la candidature
d'eric zemmour il répond sur les valeurs
et je pense qu'effectivement il a raison
de le faire parce que ce n'était pas le
jour de parts pour parler de la
politique intérieure il parle de lait
des valeurs que nous défoncer 616 que
nous défendons à l'échelle européenne et
donc moi je trouve qu'il a raison de
rappeler c'est ce qui devrait être une
évidence mais qui apparemment certains
ont oublié y compris dans la droite
républicaine c'est quand même très
sibyllin il dit pas grand chose
excusez-moi passe d'ailleurs il se dit
pourquoi ne dit pas grand chose dit que
je ne peux pas intervenir puisque on est
en campagne électorale en fin donc je
vois pas pourquoi et moi je trouvais ça
assez étrange parce qu'en fait même sur
le terrain européen les questions qui
sont posées par eric zemmour vous
viennent percuter les raisons mêmes qui
sont à l'origine de la création de
l'europe enfin on essaie de s'allier
pour ne plus se faire la guerre pour se
respecter pour faire un tourner la page
du nazisme et mme eric zemmour vient
nous raconter que pétain de gaulle c'est
la même chose il ne répond pas à ça
enfin je veux dire pourquoi il ne répond
t-il pas à ça emmanuel macron l'ue avait
déjà levé pour vous dire ça vous pouvez
pas dire ça réchauffe je considère
réalité que je comprends et le creuset
et le président de la république et le
gouvernement ont répondu largement sur
cette question de la relégitimation
rejet légitimation pardon de paix tant
par par zemmour donc on va parvenir
advitam eternam sur le sujet et en
l'occurrence là c'était pas le sujet est
la seule à la tête non ce n'est pas la
question et moi je les écoutais malades
questions et écouter la question en tout
cas la réponse et descendez création de
valeur sur eric zemmour un dernier mot
ont percé on continue un petit peu sur
ceux sur ce débat avec une citation de
leyrit pécresse et
la candidate du parti elle l est
républicain qui est portée voilà par sa
désignation est qu'ils publient dans le
monde daté de demain une tribune
notamment sur cette question de l'europe
elle a anticipé et l'avant et c'est une
réponse à la conférence de presse du
prince république je veux renforcer
l'europe à la fuir comme certains je
veux une préférence européenne pas le
repli national j'en appelle à un sursaut
européen si nous persistons dans
l'angélisme nous continuerons à nous
comporter comme le ventre mou de la
mondialisation nous tromperons dans les
oubliettes de l'histoire il faut sortir
de cette europe naïveté pour construit
avec ton père octogénaire une europe
fierté j'aurai terminé là dessus avec
vous gérard longuet est ce que
finalement ça la différencie votre
candidate d'emmanuel mâcon dans sa
conception même de l'europe et des
valeurs de l'europe d'après vous la
présidence française qu'assume emmanuel
macron le bij en effet à être courtois
et prudent avec les 26 autres pays et
donc il ne perd un peu de liberté de
parole et c'est sans doute ce qui
explique cette tonalité que vous avez
relevé madame et que tu te les hits et
modeste 20 voiliers prudente réfléchi je
crois que lé pécresse est tout à fait
dans son rôle dans ses convictions le
dire que l'europe de t'avoir ce qui
d'ailleurs une question de l'agenda une
stratégie dans le monde sauf que il
faudrait être plus précis encore hélas
le reproche que je fais à emmanuel
macron je le ferai mais les packers
c'est facile de lui dire bon on fait
quoi avec les allemands qui veulent pas
de notre nucléaire qui veulent vendre la
chine et qui préfèrent le bouclier
américain moi je suis pour l'alliance
franco allemands mais il faut quand même
mettre les vrais problèmes sur la table
et avoue la conclusion que vous aviez
oui moi j'ai lu effectivement
l'interview de valérie pécresse et elle
met également l écrit poursuivre et
amplifier la politique du green deal
mais j'ai envie de lui dire chiche sauf
que il faudrait peut-être qu'elle dise à
ses propres amis lr au parlement
européen d' arrêter de mettre des bâtons
dans les roues parce qu'on n'a pas
effectivement attendu le parti populaire
et les r pour faire de l'europe la
première puissance écologique du monde
et je pense que au bout d'un moment il
faut avoir aussi les paroles qui
corresponde avec les actes et
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire que les
l'air soit cohérent là-dessus bon merci
beaucoup de la grille n'était pas
secrétaire général des républicains elle
n'est qu'en
soutien de cette famille politique
merci beaucoup on aura l'occasion de
faire d'autres débats évidemment sur
cette thématique merci à tous d'avoir
parti d'avoir participé également à
signer matelly en duplex